twitter jusqu'à revoir et bonjour tout
le monde sait ce qu il dit à jauzion
dusautoir personnes dans un lieu de
visite m
ça va ou pas moi je m'appelle que moi
j'arrive sur le net soit toulouse mise
année
dans l'année sur leur sort tout le monde
se met
regardez c'est beau c'est incroyable la
limite vous arriviez à la puissance du
mec sur lequel redonner un excellent ça
rigole aussi là bas c'est génial on fait
une pause s'il vous plaît parce que là
c'est trop marrant déjà tu me parles
plus tôt
dans quelques mois je peux belle ta
gueule je vais en prendre pour mon grave
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire le
sous-entendu et on essaie de joie sur le
visage de gros porc de nolife
j'ai une fâcheuse tendance à renifler s
était de démons celui ci sont
particulièrement c'est quoi c'est ce
dont on a extrait ce mon corps
ok
ça s'appelle l'art est de frotter un
mois plus tard la tuna tout à leuna tout
est net tu fais mais casse toi baisse
les yeux
kitty je sais pas qui je suis moi oh oh
la la c'est fou on dirait d'atouts c'est
bon tu m'a saoulé je me casse je suis un
peu comme c'est ce qui va se passer je
vais demander aux gens de s'abonner
attaché à une pure mais ça l'a fait là
tu peux aussi partager cette vidéo sur
ton mur facebook
alors attention mon petit gars je vais
vérifier si tu as partagé alors fait
garde son abri où elle s'achète pour les
conserver merci à tous